why don't you see what I want you to
remember is if you have a nice old plain
vanilla right-angled triangle the sides
of the triangle grow light in this very
simple way which you learn in your right
cold right if you square the hypotenuse
6-man then of course it's equal to
fantastic
so I thank us learn a lot by students
around the globe okay it's really nice
and simple as they do because you can do
it right exactly
I wasn't joking now Pythagoras is great
except that it only works in these
writing the triangles okay however the
whole point of what we're doing over the
last couple of weeks is well we know
that not all triangle around angled so
what do we do when they're not so right
beside on impact on either side of this
triangle I want us to imagine what would
happen if we just modified this triangle
a little bit so that this angle here the
90 degrees with not ninety degrees okay
now here's the way we're gonna do this
please know whatever on your writing
triangle you've got for this length in
this thing I actually want you to
measure it out in fact up the top here
hey I want you to actually write those
numbers down maybe it's like three point
four centimeters or something like that
I have no idea how deep you made your
day then everyone will be different but
I just want you to know whatever those
numbers are I'm just going to put three
and four just for the sake of
convenience now he's only gonna do I'm
gonna make a pair of new triangles using
this pair science but here's the way I'm
gonna do it might be I'm holding that
for whatever your B is I want you to
make another base of a triangle with
it's the same length whatever that
happens to be then what I want you to do
is to get another side that's gonna be
the same length as a whatever your a was
but this time instead of going straight
up straight up okay I want you to lean
it over there a little bit so it's not a
right angle so I'm gonna throw my
likeness okay now it's really important
on your diagram that this a and this a
are the same
this B and this Beyonce okay now once
you've done that I want you to have a
look and we might need some colors for
this one in your original triangle is
trying whether you started with now I
want you to measure C right
for me I would have had C equals 5 okay
because it's right angle 3 squared 4
squared 5 squared I want you to measure
your own 1 okay whatever happens to be
four point five centimeters eight point
seven whatever it is and I want you to
write it just above here now this new
triangle you've made it's so much same a
it's the same babe but now it has and
I'd love you to write this in as the
case now it has an acute angle in there
instead of 90 degrees it's leaning over
okay now what I want you to notice is
what's happened to see I want you to
measure it on your own diagram okay I'm
just going to fashion a safer because
I've actually drawn this out alone it's
better the see that I got for this
triangle over here I was about four
point three now what should you think
have a look at whatever you're seeing is
do you notice
you must have whatever you started with
you must have made a new C that was
smaller did you notice that have you
measured them I don't know how much
smaller but has to be a little bit
smaller can you see why that is
do you remember it had to do with this
thing do you remember that okay I want
you to think a and B are your arms that
for some weird reason
goodnight you say blink okay when you
take that angle between the arms is how
we're doing half every time see right
when you take the angle between your
arms and you make the angle smaller what
happens to that length connecting your
hands
you also get smaller it has to do this
no choice
so say gets smaller with the angle
[Music]
okay stay with me stay with me mm-hmm
just waiting for everyone's attention
we went from a right angle triangle to
an acute triangle we noticed that C got
smaller what do you think I'm going to
do going this way I'm gonna make the
angle larger instead of leading a over
to the left I'm going to leave it to the
right they still go ahead and do that
remember a and B have to be the same
okay now again when I prepared earlier
the semen I got was 6.8 okay and again
you have something different but you
notice the size has to go in one
direction woman's the ENGOs get bigger
right that angle in the corner goes from
acute to 90 degrees to obtuse and in the
same way this side see also gets bigger
0.35 okay so with a bigger angle you get
a bigger version of the hypotenuse I
call it a version of happen is because
of course these two don't have
hypotenuse is this their wedding now
here's the beautiful thing okay the
cosine rule says it arts is the question
well if it gets smaller how much and if
it gets bigger how much and it balls it
together in one really elegant rule
here's the way it works you start with
Pythagoras write this down again for me
C squared equals a squared plus B
squared that's where it begins but and
there's a fancy proof for this that I'm
not showing you because it takes some
time it's actually not necessary for us
they adjusted a little bit you see how I
got smaller by a tiny bit that tiny bit
can be worked out with cosine this is
what it is -
it's a little bit like that half a B
sine C thing but slightly different okay
again this is on your formula sheet the
important thing I want you to notice is
where the letters are because remember
we said those are important that C must
be opposite this see it's that angle
it's okay the right thing you've got two
different cases but the cosine is so
clever that for bigger triangles you
again start with Pythagoras and cosines
does this great thing even though it
looks like you're subtracting something
if close is a sorry if Peter is obtuse
or if this angle here is the Jews
actually we should get you calculator
there on my diagram just for the sake of
consistency what would you call that
angle just give you a rough estimate 100
degrees yeah let's go with a hundred
okay if it were a hundred I want you to
take your calculator and I want you to
punch it in cause a hundred degrees now
gives you again a weird string of
decimals but the important thing is
right at the front what do you notice
about this number it's negative very
good so if this angle is obtuse and
cause of that angle is negative well if
this guy is negative what does that mean
it means to cancel out and give you a
positive which is better because C gets
bigger you wanted to add it's one rule
it's the same souped-up version of
Pythagoras's theorem that works for
everything I've got one more beautiful
little deeply it just works out it's the
same rule now say will he say oh here
what's this even if it's right angle
if that angle which we tried is not have
two degrees a second ago right if the
angle happens
exactly 19 degrees go ahead punch cause
of nineteen into your calculator and out
will give you an error on 0 because cos
ninety means no no no no don't we go
around don't get shorter don't get
bigger that is exactly right C squared a
squared B squared it's bang on you don't
need to adjust the bigger you don't need
to adjust it's smaller it's perfect
okay so the cosine rule is like it just
it works all the time there's no
ambiguity okay they're all the same yeah
well they're all literally the same
thing like I've just read on before okay
now can you come back to remember we did
a table like this and it was um it was
something like for writing the triangles
and for norm identical triangles I think
if I recall there was area sides and
then I'm missing a road angles okay I
want you to look at the cosine rule I
want you to look at the way it has been
written and significantly what is the
subject of equation
what bit both so the actual letter for
letter C squared is it
uppercase or lowercase it's lowercase
which is a it's a length right it's a
side okay so this version lock the
cosine rule belongs here okay now I
don't expect you necessarily have space
left in your table so to fit it in maybe
you can just put it here on the side but
you can write that exactly as it is and
you can use that to find science